most teachers are broke most teachers
are fat do you want your kids to be
broke and fat no so you have to
understand these people can't really
teach your kids what you want them to
know I know that's really horrible to
say but there is some truth to that do
you want your kids to grow up to be
successful entrepreneurs it depends what
you want for your kids maybe you don't
so send them to school but you are who
you surround yourself with I don't
really want my kids to be taught by
people who are broken fat so you have
that issue and the next issue is that
the curriculum is entirely changed and
it's all about promoting LGBT trans this
drag Story Hour kids are now being
exposed to really inappropriate things I
actually can't fully remember what it
was but the singer Pink I think she was
promoting a book for kids that had
literally porn in it so it's so
inappropriate and they're all doing this
in the name of equality and love it's
disgusting I don't want my children to
be exposed to drag queens to LGBT stuff
and it's nothing to do with being gay or
this or that when you're 12 years old
you don't really need to hear about it